[Musique]
à première vue c'est au bureau des plus
banal sauf que le panneau lumineux fixés
au plafond ne fait pas qu hitler et la
pièce in ternet aussi de se connecter à
internet
après le wifi voici le l'ifi la seule
différence avec le wifi si le routeur
wifi lui transmet des données à travers
des radiofréquences donc des ondelettes
rang magnétique le lit fille lui va
transmettre les données à travers le
spectre lumineux l'éclairage de type
dell qui inclut des composantes
électroniques est à la base de cette
technologie
le panel est le dé lui permet d'envoyer
la lumière enfin d'envoyer les données à
travers la lumière et au milieu vous
voyez qu'il ya un petit récepteur donc
ce petit récepteur la permet le renvoi
l'information mais comment la lumière
transmettaient les données
elle va clignoter des millions de fois
par seconde et ça va créer des héros
indien un peu comme du morse exactement
de la même manière mais des millions de
fois plus rapide
global digit ecc commercialise la
technologie mise au point par
l'entreprise française oled comme fondés
en 2012
son équipe vient de mettre en marché une
lampe vendus mais 700 $ pour ceux qui
souhaitent accéder ou l'ifi sent pas
cette câble dans les plafonds
le marché avait besoin de ce genre de
produit pour se démocratiser puisse se
faire connaître c'est un produit qui est
facilement connectables on pourrait
avoir chaque pièce ici représenterait un
magasin puis un point lumineux ton
constructeur le l'ifi permet aussi de
géo localisé très précisément les
appareils qui sont connectés la
technologie est déjà utilisée dans
certains musées européens pour que les
tablettes et les appareils mobiles des
visiteurs se transforme en audioguide
suffit d'être sous la lumière
je déclenche le contenu sous cette lente
quand je mets sous celle là ici
sur zone et le procédé pourrait aussi
être utilisée dans les magasins afin
d'envoyer des offres promotionnelles ou
clients selon le réunion où il se trouve
patrick bruel et son équipe ont conclu
un partenariat avec l'uqam pour
installer le wifi dans ce laboratoire
on teste multitude de nouvelles
technologies qui entourent des objets
connectés
je comprend deux modèles et je les vends
sortie réussie au cours des prochains
mois le professeur rigal bendavid de ses
étudiants mettront le lift y ait des
preuves d'un point de vue pratique aux
pratiques la faisabilité technique l
élan je les ai vus vous l'avez vu le
business case ou qui va permettre de
justifier les investissements dans des
technologies comme ça je le connais pas
encore et c'est justement ce qu'on va
voir ici dans ce lab global l'ifi tech
estime que le défi comporte certains
avantages par rapport au wifi qui
pourraient charme et d'éventuels clients
il est plus rapide et plus difficilement
piratable les données vont rester dans
l'environnement du spectre lumineux
donc il n'est pas possible de venir à
quai à moins évidemment que le hacker se
trouve à côté de vous selon lui le défi
sera d'abord déployé dans les
entreprises et les institutions avant de
gagner chez résidentiel vidéotron
s'intéresse cette technologie tout comme
air canada qui fera installer le wifi à
l'aéroport de montréal dans ses salons
destinés à la clientèle d'affaires une
ville comme montréal pourrait aussi
l'utiliser grâce aux lampadaires d'elle
ici olivier vachon radio canada montréal